What is another
name for angle CPA?
So we have C, we have
P, and we have A.
So angle CPA is going to be
this angle right over here.
So what's another name for it?
Well, I could start off with A,
and I could call it angle APC.
So this is the same
thing as angle APC.
Now is that any
one of my choices?
Yeah, that's this
choice right over here.
If someone said angle P,
that wouldn't give you
a lot of information.
That kind of says, well, that's
only giving me one point.
I don't know, maybe
it's referring
to that angle, that angle,
that angle, that angle.
So that's really not giving
me enough information
to specify this angle
right over here.
Angle PAC would be an angle
formed if you actually
had a line here, if you
had a line between AC.
Angle PAC would be
this angle right
over here, which is
clearly a different angle.
Angle FPA would be
this angle right
over here, which is also
clearly a different angle.
So the only choice that
makes sense is angle APC.